Imagine a notion where water is constantly boiling it's boundless.
There is no coast in sight. It stretches as far as the horizon.
Although this fact is evasive to the observer because as far as the eye can see,
the horizon is constantly shrouded in dense fog,
thick clouds with not a Ching between them hide a huge,
but dim sun only negligible changes and level of light indicate
transitions from nights to days and nights. Again,
if it has stopped being pitch dark and its deep gray around you,
it means sunrise and deep down under scores of kilometers
of water. Their lies are billion to of scorching ice.
This is where the unique and mysterious world of glee 1214 B
must look like
the first outer space.
The first steps in theoretical confirmation of there being ocean worlds out
there that is planets fully covered in water were made back in the 1970s.
That is when evidence was found,
the Tradeo active decay in a planets interior and title forces may cause water
ice to melt and subsequently form huge oceans in all likelihood
similar processes, take sun Jupiter and Saturns satellites.
However,
these celestial bodies remain eyes bound as they lie too far away from the sun
whose raise would otherwise melt the thick layers of ice.
But when we talk about an ocean planet,
a slightly different type of space objects is meant.
The term implies that the ocean and on a planet surface,
isn't concealed under a layer of ice and its depth measures more than a hundred
kilometers theoretical calculations of these planet's formation and evolution
processes were carried out in 2004 by French astrophysicists headed by
Christo Satan. According to this theory,
if the mass of forming planet is more than 10 times out of the earth,
this starts to actively attract hydrogen and helium from the gas and dust cloud
around it. In this manner. With time, it grows into a gas giant.
By contrast, if this planet's mass is just six to eight earth masses,
the new planet is going to be comprised of by ice and rocks,
roughly an equal measure,
just to compare the mass total of all water in the global ocean on our earth
accounts for just 0.0 to 5% of the Earth's total mass
in this case provided a space object. Sobi lies far from the host star.
This object is going into be either a ice giant or a cold super earth
radioactive decay taking place inside the core will help melt some portion of
the ice,
which its turn will help form a subsurface ocean by the planet's outer
will still remain frozen. If the planet happens to find itself in its stars,
habitable zone,
its outta layers will melt and spill all over the surface in a boundless ocean
theoretical calculations show that a planet with a mass six to eight times out
of the earth may have a layer of water over a hundred kilometers thick.
The pressure exerted by this amount of water may reach 20,000 atmospheres
depending on temperature, impurities and other parameters.
This is enough for some special exotic varieties of ice to form like one's
remaining solid. Even at high temperatures. In addition,
unlike the familiar water ice,
these modifications would be heavier than liquid water. For example,
the density of ice seven,
which is likely to form in these conditions should be around
1,650 kilos per cubic meter.
This ice settles on the planet,
SOS bottom and forms a massive cryosphere that envelopes. The more massive core,
the opportunity to put these theoretical assumptions to test arose when a tiny
and dim star was spotted 42 light years away from the earth,
it was dubbed G glacier 1214.
The diameter of this red dwarf turned down to be five times smaller than that of
the sun with its mass, just 15.7%.
That of the sun at the same time, Lisa 12,
14 is 300 times dimmer than our parents star.
While it's surface temperature is only 3000 Calvin or
2,700 degrees Celsius.
There is nothing particularly remarkable about the star itself to be blunt.
It is just another non-descript red dwarf that looks like any of the billions of
other stars in our galaxy. However, in 2009,
a solitary planet was detected in its environments,
which was dubbed Gleer 1214 B with this diameter measuring
two and a half times out of the earth.
This exoplanet is just six and a half times heavier than our home planet.
Straightforward calculations show the free fall acceleration on the exoplanet
surface to be just 91%. That of the earth.
The average density of glee at 1214 B is approximately
1,870 kilos per cubic meter
judging by this comparatively small value.
The exoplanet counter realistically be made up of mostly metals and rocks as
is the case with our earth, for example, but incidentally,
this average density value seems to confirm the assumption.
The astronomical body is 75% water or water rice and just
25% trucks.
Thus it appears safe to suggest that this exoplanet is a ocean planet.
The object lies very close to its host star.
The average distance between them measures just around 2 million kilometers or
0.014 astronomical units,
which is 75 times smaller than that between the earth and the sun.
Also the Orix centricity is rather high at 0.27,
slightly more than of Pluto. This means that in its peril,
glee 1214 B is approximately twice as close to its star.
Then when in its ahe, as for its orbital period,
it takes the planet about 36 hours to complete it.
The RevB war glee 12, 14,
maybe 300 times dimmer than the sun,
but this incredible proximity to the star makes the climate on glee 12,
14 B scorching hot supposing the reflection coefficient of the surface of
Gleer 1214 B is the same as start of Venus.
The planet's surface temperature is supposed to be around 393 Calvin
or 120 degrees Celsius. If on the other hand,
the surface is darker.
The temperature may reach as much as 553 Calvin or
280 degrees Celsius due to the fact that the orbit of
Gleer 12, 14, B crosses to stars,
disc scientists are able to carry out spectro topic investigations of its
atmosphere. Still the results are rather ambiguous.
If this space object truly is an ocean planet,
its atmosphere is supposed to predominantly consist of water vapor with summer
accompanying gases, interestingly,
no lines of hydrogen helium,
or complex substances like water to CO2 and amonia have so far been
detected in the planet spectrum.
It has stored that the outer layer of the dense atmosphere conceals its true
content from the observer,
the conditions on the surface of Gleer 1214 B remind one of what it is
like inside a giant steam boiler. Interestingly,
the atmospheric pressure in its lowest strata should be at least 15 times as
high as out of the earth as the ocean and the atmosphere are in a state of
thermodynamic equilibrium. The border between them is rather blurred.
No wonder as the density of water vapor just above the ocean's surface is
practical to that of constantly boiling water.
As we'll look deeper at the lowest Strat of the ocean,
the pressure will continue to increase until we reach the depth of a hundred
kilometers.
With the pressure value of this depth water will be unable to remain in its
liquid state, even at temperatures this high.
And so we will see the bottom made up of dense and heavy ice whose thickness is
estimated to be upwards of 5,000 kilometers.
Thus most water on the planet is concentrated here below the
cryosphere. There should be the core made up of rocks and metals.
Unfortunately,
chances of life evolving on any ocean planet are rather thin.
Even if the surface temperature happens to be more favorable than on this one.
This is so due to the fact that oceans on planets like that are to poor in terms
of micro elements that are vital for living creatures,
even taking into account meteorites that occasionally bombard the surfaces of
these celestial bodies.
The chemical diversity is simply not good enough for life to originate here,
Still studying ocean planets poses, a great scientific interest.
According to NASA's mathematical modeling estimates published in 2020,
there may be billions of planets of this type in our galaxy,
both cold harboring an ocean under an ice shell and warm like
Gleer 1214,
B water is one of the most widespread complex chemical
compounds in the unit us.
And this means that the chances of discovering new ocean planets are quite
optimistic. Meanwhile,
feel free to hit the like button and subscribe if you still haven't done.
So your support greatly boosts our motivation and inspires us to make
new, interesting and informative videos. Let's keep in touch.
The, I.